We have a voicemail number, which is two one
nine two David P..
I love this voicemail.
This is a delightful caller who thinks Trump
may have lied about how great he is for black
Americans.
Take a listen to this, one of my new favorite
callers.
Well, I am definitely going to vote for vice
president.
We all Americans need to go out there and
vote for November 3rd.
Yes, we need to get that dangerous person
out of the White House.
He's very dangerous.
And he is a racist prevalently.
Oh, I.
He's in he's done more for black people in
any president, any tell a lie.
That's right.
Which we all know how top lives we do.
And of course, always welcome the David Pakman
show playing in the background while the caller
leaves a voicemail.
Yes.
You are completely right.
Donald Trump's claims about how great he's
been for black America is that there are claims
that that are a joke.
We debunk them individually.
We've got to get them out.
It is more or the last 48 hours.
And what happened at the rally have renewed
the urgency of removing this guy on the bonus
show today, by the way, and other reason to
get him out.
Donald Trump has a new plan for ending DACA.
Last week, the Supreme Court rejected Trump's
argument for why DACA should be canceled.
And we said he's going to try it again and
he may win if he tries it again.
There is a plan that could take six months
to complete.
Trump will still be in office in six months.
But oh, wait.
No, no, no.
Oh, yes.
March.
December.
Yeah.
He will still be in office in six months,
but he will be close to out if if if if we
replace him in November by voting for Joe
Biden.
And no surprise that there is a new plan.
We'll tell you what it is to get rid of DACA
on the bonus show.
We will also talk about the project to map
the ocean floor.
Very interesting science project.
And I'll tell you why it matters.
And we will also tell you the latest coronavirus
shortage.
We had toilet paper.
We then had bicycle's.
It is now coins, coins.
And I will explain why.
Become a member and get instant access at.
Join Pacman dot com.